hi guys in this video we're gonna talk
about how to cure erectile dysfunction
okay now if you look this up you'll see
a whole bunch of confusing articles and
research they say it's complex condition
caused by heart disease high cholesterol
high blood pressure diabetes obesity
metabolic syndrome which is basically
these right here and kidney disease okay
that's what they're telling you that's
causing it but if we look behind these
problems there's a common denominator
these are symptoms of insulin resistance
which is a pre-diabetic situation and
that's a high insulin situation it might
not even show up in your blood Sugar's
but it definitely will show up if you do
a fasting insulin test
high levels of the insulin destroy the
lining of the arteries it targets
something called the endothelial layer
of your vascular system and then comes
the cascade of other issues relating to
heart disease and blood pressure and all
sorts of things but it first starts as a
dysfunction of the circulation okay and
that is why there's a low success in
taking testosterone because taking
testosterone doesn't necessarily fix and
some resistance it might help you
temporarily but unless you get this
corrected you can't get this corrected
okay so how do you do it get on a
ketogenic diet do intermittent fasting
cut out the alcohol the smoking now as
far as medication certain medications
will cause this condition too so you
have to get with your doctor and work
out a plan to come off the medications
as you get healthy cleaning up your diet
okay
lowering cortisol that's stress do what
you can to get more sleep go for long
walks but you just definitely need to
lower the cortisol and avoid high
fructose corn syrup okay it's in so many
foods that causes insulin resistance
big-time but even more than that soy oil
also will cause insulin resistance so
start reading the labels avoid soy oil
at all cost and start doing like olive
oil and other types of oils
right so I have a lot more videos on how
to do ketosis in a minute fasting I'll
put some links down below check it out
hey if you haven't already subscribed
press the button below and I will keep
you in the know
hey that runs